okay thanks Andre yeah so so I was asked
to talk about random instances and then
I saw the program and that notice that
time only one of two speakers that will
talk about this topic so i decided to
take it up on me to try to convince you
that our random instances are an
interesting topic yeah so this will be a
brief introduction so i'll try to give a
very high level survey of these subjects
that I think are very interesting so
this is a knowledge the fact that I have
two small kids so I started learning
something all right so you all know what
is satisfiability right so you have n
variables and boolean variables 0 1 and
then you have to settle you want to
despite MK closes which closes is the
disjunction of K variables so or their
negation okay and you want to satisfy
all of them and okay there is there is
of course many version of this problem
that we will talk about decision is the
resolution optimization maximize the
number of satisfied closes over all
possible assignment and Counting that is
connected to things that we heard about
today is counted number of solutions of
such an instance
and okay something that I will use you
know quite a bit through the talk is the
representation of an instance as a graph
okay so you can think of an instance
either as a hypergraph or as a factor
graph so here I gave the factor graph
representation the factor graph is a
graph with two types of nodes note that
correspond to variables so boolean
variables and notes that correspond so
these are a little circles and notes
that correspond to factors these are
little square and they put an edge
between a factor and the variable node
if and only if that variables appears in
the corresponding close so for instance
this is my representation of the clues x
5 x 7 not x 9 not extend and the dashed
edge put a dash edge when there is a
negation and this is a simple claw a
simple formula where n variables and and
foreclosures okay so so so what is no
standard mainstream complexity theory is
about following question is there an
algorithm that works well for all
instances of this problem so for all
graph G so often I will denote my stance
as a graph it is understood that can
this can be a decorated graph like in my
example so is there an instance that
work well for all the instances random
instances tries to do something
different we define a probability
distribution over instances p of g and
then we ask is there an algorithm that
works with I probability when you draw G
from to this probability distribution ok
so now works what works means might mean
many things but you know for instance
finds a solution in this problem with a
probability ok so there are many reasons
really to be pessimistic about whatever
this approach can can tell you and this
is why this is not a mainstream approach
first of all there is many possible
choices of this of this probability
measure who should tell us you
which one is the best okay you know when
you start thinking of this means that
you need you know to get out of your of
your room and try to model director a
little bit aerial instances so in a
sense you need to model the real world
and if you're just interested in
complexity theory this is something that
you don't want to spend time on no third
is very important you know random
instances are not robust to reductions
beautiful things about you know
complexity theory is reductions and and
because of that is very difficult to
prove or nearly you know lower bounds
for interesting distribution of a
trundle instance it's very difficult to
prove that things are hard in any in any
in any meaningful sense it's possible to
prove that they are easy but not that
they are hard so I want to go against
this this argument and claim that that
still random instances are interesting
and then I'll come back through this
list of motivations at the end of the
talk meet at mid of the token center and
the above the talk there are some
classical motivation that is why people
started studying random instances and if
you look back and papers in the eighties
typical motivations where first one is
ok we have many heuristics for solving
satisfiability we want to compare them
how should we compare them just let's
throw random instances at them and and
you know the second is a little bit more
philosophical ok we know that random
instance is hard but what are there
exists but what do they look like when
you cannot construct anyone explicitly
so the next best thing is that you can
construct them by a probabilistic
construction I'll tell you what are my
motivations they are not this this
motivation first motivation is that
these are actually often i claim good
models for problems that are actually
important ok and this is becoming more
and more so because of the explosion of
machine learning your computational
statistics etc right in all of those
things often people come up with study
ethical model that is probabilistic
model for computational problems right
and you want to analyze those
statistical models and you know people
mark your work hard for modeling those
and and so we should take them seriously
second you know something that is a
merge quite recent quite clearly over
the last eight years there is some
beautiful mathematics in the theory of
random instances that involves
probability theory and statistical
mechanics and third your by analyzing
random instances people have come up
with with your nice algorithmic ideas so
one is that will talk about the bitties
message passing algorithm local
algorithms there has been quite some
actually a lot of work on convex
relaxation on all sorts of random
instances and you know as given this is
the outline of my talk I'll give some
example and history starting from
scratch then discuss some structural
problem properties discuss it certain
types of models that are related to
applications and planted models and then
computational properties some examples
okay so this is my picture before for
Sun satisfiability when people started
finding how to put a probability
distribution one of the first ideas now
I don't know what is which one is the
very first papers that does this but
this was the pretty old paper was ok
I'll do is draw a formula uniformly at
random or equivalently I'll draw each
Clause independently nearly equivalently
each close independently among all the
possible ones so are many possible
clauses of K variables I can generate
and choose K because i have to pick the
key variables x 2 to the K because I can
negate or direct each of the literals ok
so you know I sample m closes
independently from this distribution ok
so people started studying this and and
this was one of the first things that
they discover is covered ok so this is a
from a paper by by Scott Cleopatra can
bart salman also quite old paper what
they did here is they plotted for values
several values of case or two three four
five six they plotted worth the
generating random instances with this
distribution and different values of N
and they plotted the probability that
that distance admits a solution as a
solution they solved it Bassam your
exhaustive method and this is for some
small sizes and then what they notice is
the following that take for instance I
don't know k equal so we said this is
perhaps six k equal six if you do this
for a small values of n the empirical
probability goes from 0 to 1 in a small
window around the point okay and then if
you take n large error it gains it goes
again from zero close to zero to close
to one in a in a in a small window and
if you take enlarger also goes from
close to zero close to one in an even
smaller window and the transition
becomes sharper and sharper as n gets
larger and larger okay so these three
curves are three values of n for the
same K so this is this kind of finding
led people to formulate the following
conjecture it's known as satisfiability
conjecture there exists forever k there
existed you know a critical point of
alpha so what is here the parameter is
the number of clues over a number of
variables there is a critical value of
this ratio such that instances random
instances are satisfied with that
probability you know below this this
value and there are unsatisfiable with I
probability above this value
does this make sense to everybody okay
so this is you know I think from the
same paper or a similar paper by by
Republican sermon they did it more
careful for very best value of values of
N and for instance they quote
numerically d following your approximate
value for K equals 3 4 point 17 we see
that is not quite right but is not too
far off okay so this was interesting so
a random formula or not you know soft
with some probability satisfiable or
some probability unsatisfiable but they
are depending of the number of closest /
variable are either you know mostly
satisfiable or mostly unsatisfiable know
why is that and the second thing it was
a computational phenomenon that they
noticed this is actually from a popular
science paper as i remember reading this
when I was an undergraduate and this is
what got me interested in soil and they
solved it with some young exhaustive
search and they found it that if you
plot the number of operations versus the
same parameter alpha this is a small
alpha it's very easy because you have
very few constraints at large alpha is
harder but still not too hard because
there is lots of constraints oak will
quickly find out that the problem cannot
be satisfied and in between there is a
peak and this peak is very close to this
four point 17 so the phase transition
was at first plane 17 and they found the
peak was at the same roughly the same
position why is that so these two things
spurred a lot of work and we talked
about it so I use these sets for bility
as as a running example but i want to
mention two other examples so what is
one thing that is beautiful about this
is that the same theory that is still
not there but is not being developed the
seems to apply to a huge number of
examples they just leave all the time
since
another example is random graph coloring
ouuu you generate an instance of
coloring simply as follows you generate
a random graph for end vertices and
linked down each edge with probability d
over n so this is a nerd or any random
graph we bounded average degree average
degrees d and then you ask yourself the
question can I find a proper coloring
with Q colors where q is bigger equal
than three the case Q equal to is easy
third example that has some differences
from the previous ones but is still
interesting is Randall cakes or soft in
this case again the variables are our
boolean 01 and and the constraint so you
have constrained each constraint
involves k variables and each constraint
is really a linear equation of a que
variables okay so you have a set of em a
linear equation each equation involves k
variables okay so the equation looks
like this and the distribution is again
a sample each equation uniformly at
random among all the possible one there
is n choose K possible ways of choosing
the left hand suicide and two ways to
choose the right hand side so so in this
case this is a little bit different from
the previous ones because of course the
decision problem it's an accounting
problem or easy their interest is
similar in another respect okay
structural properties I what I mean by
this is the question now first question
is does the random formula of solutions
and the following question is you know
somehow what does this solution look
like so you know the main thing that
attracted people in this in this in this
area is okay can we prove the
satisfiability conjecture can we prove
that
actually Rando formula undergo a phase
transition okay so a piece of notation
so that is the simplest method to
approach this this problem is the the
method of moments so I want just to
explain this because it's really the
simplest way of getting bounced it
doesn't get you all the way to the
threshold but it gets you interesting
buttons so how does this work okay the
set of solution so let's think of a
problem with boolean variables so the
space of possible solution is the
boolean hypercube 0 1 to n the set of
solution of a given orondo formula is a
random subset of this hypercube that I
will indicate bias calligraphic test so
i'll concede the number of solutions so
the cardinality of this set what is the
moment method it's a way to get upper
and lower bound the upper bound is very
easy now and so the upper bound is what
you want to prove the priority want to
show that the formula is satisfiable is
unsatisfiable so you want to upper bound
the probability that there this bigger
or equal than one that there exists at
least one solution now so you do markov
inequality this is it mostly expectation
of death now the expectation is that is
what is the number of possible you know
assignment possible 01 vector times the
probability that any of this vector is a
solution this is you know just depend on
that the priority that any of this
vector is the solution the while this is
the probability that each clause is
satisfied since closes are independent
is probability that one clause is
satisfied raise to power m what is the
probability that the close of random
case art is satisfied well the only way
you don't satisfy it is that now you
forbid every single assignment of every
single literal so it's 1 by 2 to the K
the probability that is not satisfied so
this is probability that is satisfied so
this is just you expand this and you get
n log 2 minus n alpha dog too and you
notice that there is an N on front so
this probability goes to zero as soon as
this term beats vista so this implies
that when alpha is molar is bigger you
know then then to k log to this goes to
zero so alpha is bigger than the smaller
than 2k look too okay so this is a
simple upper bound so remarkably took a
while even to match the two to the K in
this expression so I go ahead with the
moment method so you want to prove a
lower bound so you want lower bound the
probability that that is bigger or equal
than one now by a kind of fancy name the
variant of kosher farts this is lower
bounded by the expectation of dead
square divided by the expectation by the
second moment now we like to prove that
this goes to one an important
simplification is that it is sufficient
to prove that this is God bonded away
from 0 namely you know if you know that
if you know that you your that bigger or
equal than one is bounded below by some
delta positive then you know also the
limit as n to infinity p of that video
but one is equal to one okay so this is
not not an easy factories you know it's
a consequence of a theorem by Fred good
that shows the following it doesn't show
that the satisfiability property as a
sharp threshold ok it proved that it as
a phase transition as a precise point
but it proves that it has a sharp that I
showed around a value alpha is that can
you know eventually depend on n ok so a
random formula pass from satisfiable to
unsatisfiable in this very small window
you know across a on
around the threshold that can depend on
n so because of that as you know if you
know that this is bounded away from zero
then you know that you're below ok so
it's sufficient to prove to get lower
and upper back a lower bound on of ice
on satisfiability threshold sufficient
prove that the second moment is upper
bounded by some constant independent of
Edna times the square of the first
moment all right so you can try to do
that and you can we can try to do the
calculation for satisfiability I will
not do it in the interest of time it's
not hard but interesting one interesting
thing is it doesn't work for ke saath
now this is a method that is so simple
and it is that there are a billion of
reasons why it doesn't work ok but I
will always start from from one of these
reason so the reason why you know when
the second moment matches the square of
of the first moment it means that so
let's look what is this a moment the
second moment the expectation the second
voltage is the sum over all x and y of
the probability that x and y satisfy my
random formula ok let's call the round
the formula see whatever it is right so
so while the first moment
when you do this calculation you realize
that the case in which the second moment
is the square of the first moment is
when the x and y that dominate the some
are the XM pairs x and y that they are
basically they are uncorrelated okay
they are independent if you look at the
joint type of these two vectors so the
number of vertices where they are 0 0 0
1 1 0 1 1 this joint type the empirical
distribution of these two vectors factor
izes when this phenomenon happens then
the product the the second moment
becomes closer to the square of the
first moment so this happens when this
property on this sum is maximized where
pairs X Y that whose type is factorized
is independent so this doesn't happen
for kiss after why well doesn't happen
for k started because of the following
if you take a random formula you know I
variables in this random formula might
be directed remember that the graph
representation remember that I indicated
by dashed line every time that ACLU's is
negating that variable and the
continuously line every time that ACLU's
is having that variable in directed for
right so this variable in this passion
small formula that I draw is directed in
all the clauses that it belongs to so
you expect that if you take two random
solution the value of this of this
variable will be correlated because we
will tend to satis it will tend to be
true in both random solution so simply
because of these local buyers for ke
saath there is no value of alpha in
which this happens so if you do this not
only you don't get a good bound but you
get no bound whatsoever
ok so for fixing this yeah the trick
that was used that the idea that was
used there was to change the definition
of that right I want to prove that you
know this palette Sigmund inequalities
to about any random variable set there's
to be non negative but it's true for any
random variable tech right so you want
to take a random if you take a random
variable that is you know you want to
take a random variable that that is
positive as soon as the formula is
satisfiable and you want to get rid of
this problem of the local buyers of the
fact that in most new solution this
variable will take value true ok so the
first way that the you know people are
helped us and were found to solve or go
around this problem was the following
instead of counting the number of
solution I count the number of not all
equal satisfying solutions whether a no
count number of solution but I count the
number of assignment that satisfies
close and satisfy also the opposite of
the same clothes where the opposite of
clothes I mean the clothes that is
obtained by that by changing each
literal in its leg negation so in other
words for each Clause if this is if this
is a closed appearing in my formula I
want my assignment to be a special type
not only to satisfy this close I want it
to satisfy also this close
so in a sense I'm shooting myself in the
foot right because because i'm not you
know there might be a lot of of
satisfying assignment but you know a lot
less of not all equal satisfying
assignment so i'm shooting myself in the
foot but what I'm gaining is the fact
that now you know I'm canceling the bias
and canceling this type of bias here in
fact if you do this calculation they
were able to use calculation and you got
a bound that is roughly a factor to
below this real satisfiability blow the
upper bound okay so they got for first
time the fact of 2 to the K but they got
a factor 2 in front frog it's because
they basically they double the number of
constraints that we were trying to
satisfy all right a smarter idea was
used in a paper by it by does not
impressed what they did is okay I don't
need to be so cruel I just satisfy you
know each close and its opposite what
I'll do is just construct a waiter
design kind of fight again this natural
bias so the natural bias for a random
solution is to go in the direction of
the majority of the literals that it
belongs to instead I put here a number
you know smaller than one raised as to
the number of literals satisfied by X so
not all you know solutions are created
equal there are some solution that
satisfies of literals some solution that
satisfies literals and I look for the
solution that satisfy less literals
because no solution are less prone to
these bias now it's not obvious but it's
a result of the calculation that if you
take this exponential wait now this will
save my random variable and make the
second moment work up to you know a
non-trivial threshold and in particular
in this way they were able to prove
our fight is between two to the K log 2
minus K into Sotillo 2 so this was about
second moment and air rescuing the
second moment method by this by this
problem to move beyond this ah ah the
step forward you know beyond this kind
of moment method came from from
statistical physics and a crucial idea
was that okay you have to really
understand this satisfiability phase
transition you have to understand
somehow the geometry of this piece of
solutions it's not enough to study every
single so somebody to understand how
they are related okay and you know turns
out that this was related you know you
can think about your geometry in another
way you can think instead of so by
geometry of the space of solution what I
mean is the following we talked about it
a bit more this is a random subset of
the boolean hyper cool tube it's
geometry is a subset of this metric
space but turns out that you know in the
physics situation this was related to
another your team that is ok if you look
at the uniform measure over solution
what are its special mixing properties I
will not talk about this in any in unity
but the two are closely related in the
physics theory so how much correlation
that is between variables in a random
solution yeah so it turns out that using
these ideas and no method from
statistical physics in in 2002 mejor
para sins Akina were able to compute
exactly now give exact conjectures for
the threshold of random ke saath in
particular for k equal 3 DS gave you
this number 4 point 2 667 now this this
you know the real physics theory as you
know a formula for this is a formula
that takes a few few slides so perhaps
one slide so I am NOT brave enough to
copy it here but you know as you see
this is in the right ballpark and was
conjectured to be exact not approximate
if you remember the numerical
calculation was 4.17
okay so so you know for talking about
this issue at the geometry i want you
have to have to set a couple of
definitions so again variables are in 01
so so let's do the following fix a scale
so this is a distance that tells me
whether two solutions are closer or far
apart this is a scale elephant that goes
infinity with them so and and I will
take it to be small oven and then for
any two solutions i will say that they
are closed if there are humming
distances below this scale and then what
I'll do is simply I take the spatial
displace the set of solution and
quotient it by this equivalence relation
presented by the closure of this
equivalence relation all right so this
gives me a partition of the of the the
set of solutions into clusters the
equivalence relation is not really this
is the closure of this so two solutions
are our relative there is no a path
between that with step of this sides
now this this is a bit you know this
definition is a bit tricky because okay
you have to fix this scale this might
seem arbitrary but somehow we know you
know in the cases that are well
understood there is a basically any
value of the scale that you take make
sense the maximum Hamming distance is
then and basically any anything because
between poly log and n over poly log
gives the same partition basically and
the picture that emerged from these
papers is okay more or less the
following the depending on alpha 3 three
scenarios happen how phase you know the
fraction of clothes the closest /
variable above the satisfiability
threshold that there is no solution but
then there is two more phase transitions
and they correspond to the following
below this that is called the dynamic
color clustering or shattering phase
transition there is basically only one
equivalence class when this partition
between this dynamical and the second
phase transition that i'll call the
condensation phase transition there is
exponentially many equivalence classes
so solution get shattered or separated
in small clusters that are well
separated and in this final interest
interval there is only order one of
these clusters but more than one
actually a random number so this is
normally very confusing so I will try to
explain it more more formally okay this
33 scenario so what I mean by this is
the following take these clusters and
order them by cardinality so you have c1
c2 CN so then the following actors in
the in the first regime see one takes a
fraction for any excess all of these are
statement that our conjecture told with
our probability so c1 takes 1 minus
epsilon times s for any positive epsilon
so as all the mass there can be some
some powder out there but it's all of it
in this interval to make all the massive
together a big
bunch of guys and how many you have to
put them together you have to put
together exponentially many into then
Sigma and each of them is basically the
same size takes up a fraction into the
mines n Sigma and finally somehow the
most the finery gym then the following
happens think of putting together the
first q clusters for any fixed Q and
compute what fraction of the total mass
this makes now in the in the in the
first case you get one in the second
case you will get zero in the staircase
you get a random variable that is a
non-degenerate random variable is
something that is strictly between zero
and one and as you know a well-defined
distribution so it's like when you take
it you take a piece of bread and you
break it at a random point then you take
you know what is left on one side on the
right side and you break it at a random
point and then you take what is left and
you break it at a random point etc and
then you are there your pieces of bright
you get bread pieces of bread of order
one but around the size in the second
case what's the quantification like what
it is they say that for every I'm not if
you want the summation to be more than
11 sep short answers m needs to be at
least that much what so it's not for any
am not there exists I'm not and I'm
aware I'm is of this side where this
happens right so I'm not I want to okay
I could take I could do I could do the
following I take a from the largest up
to em I could have stated in this way
there is take all the cluster from the
first one to the enth one this would
they make these mass
there would they steal that this many
I'm not is much smaller than this but
there would not be all of equal size
okay so in other words there can be some
a few ones that are much bigger so the
typical size of a cluster is this this
one if you take a random solution
typically it happens to be in a cluster
of this side it's like I take you know
my my stick and then I break it in some
big pieces but still small of one then I
break most of it in exponentially many
pieces all of the same size so those big
pieces are bigger than the rest but the
young they really you know do not matter
if you take a random point in the
interval it will happen to be in one of
the small pieces so they exist AM NOT
and in Sigma such that 1 minus epsilon
fraction of s yeah it's containing two
sets of size roughly igloo the other
sites of this size you're all be setting
this you know there exists a mmm
clusters where m is of disorder and they
are all of this size and they make up 10
minus epsilon of all the you know
now there exists also bigger clusters
but they don't add up to so much they
don't add up to much any fact that is a
whole new sparrow as you imagine it's
not that there is big and small there is
a whole distribution of them all right
so this is the picture that emerged in
these physics papers and was entirely no
right rigorous and over years people
have proved our parts of these so one
there is one special case in which you
can prove a lot of things very precisely
and this is kicks or sat because but
since it's a linear system or cluster
zip equal size so now people proved
basically everything that you might want
okay you might of always want to know
more but all of this picture but it's
considerably simpler ins in the sense
that is right in the sense of the class
that are equal and there is no face no
no intermediate phase here so this
condensation phase coincide with the
phase transition here so that's it's a
simpler case because of linear of linear
algebra in case of this mobility there
are partial result in the sense that
this is also any Q coloring partial
result so in what sense these are
partial and in the sense that they are
typically they hold for large enough k
or large enough number of colors and
they typically gets bounced on our face
and alpha C and so they don't get your
sharp threshold for this phase
transition and they typically sometimes
they give you the number of clusters and
sometimes not so for instance this this
result gives you your sharp eyes out on
the number of clusters but you know for
instance this result doesn't give you a
short number of result of clusters so
for instance for me up to be concrete
for small K the question is open or
another question is open is typically
prove that these clusters are internally
connected well connected it's easier to
prove that they are well separated but
they're connected internally
okay so now this might seem a long
digression this on the geometry of space
of solution we started with your comp
doing something very concrete counting
the number of solutions or you know this
has very threshold and now I did this
hole digger a digression into you know
what is the geometry of the space of
solution the point is that this was
crucial in also getting a rigorous
result for this threshold okay so I
explained you that you know the second
moment method fails because this kind of
local biases that induces correlation in
general second moment method fails when
you know to random assignment that
called to typical assignment that
contribute to this some are uncorrelated
okay but if you think at this
intermediate regime now think of drawing
two random assignment from the uniform
measure of our solution they will
typically are with positive probability
folding the same clusters so they insane
cluster so they will be correlated so
they will be under the uniform measure
there will be a positive correlation now
you know the measure that you get when
you get second moment is even worse
measure but this suggests that is this
interval no matter how you you know
painfully improve your second moment
method by constructing carefully your
random variable you will be in trouble
in particular what what what happens in
this regime is that the typical value of
the number solution is much smaller than
the expectation
this is true even now if you truncate
this expectation typically when this
happens what what what people do is put
here an indicator over the local
structure of the graph but this doesn't
cure this problem in that regime alright
so again there are you know we can go on
and on in discussing the intuition of
this but this is what I described just
now alright so the idea to overcome this
is the following what you should do is
not count the number of solution but
counting the number of clusters and this
turns out that have ya again in the
physics picture many other
characterization for instance there are
a number of fixed point of this
algorithm that I'll discuss in a minute
belief propagation are number of fixed
point of a certain whitening process so
what min process is a process that takes
a cluster and shrieks it down to a point
you know recursively replacing each
variable that can take both 0 and 1
value by a star so in SS assignment in
01 start to the end that is you know
collapses a cluster in one point so
these kind of ideas were present in a
very you know you know rigorous way in
the physical attraction for instance in
this paper there was a described
description of this whitening procedure
but they were really made the rigorous
in in the work of a mean kirkland & jung
nike and others life and in particular
this this is a key step in improving
this theorem by by the incline sun that
is ok for all k large enough random
cassatt as a structure so this proves
the satisfiability attraction and again
is given by this physics prediction that
I will not I will not write down the T
you know ok there are it's a very
complicated moment but one key
ingredient is do the second moment
method but counting the number of
clusters and using as a proxy for
cluster these white and solutions
Oh an late time so I want to discuss two
more things one is planted model and the
other is computational implications so
what are planted models so so far what
we did is that we generated random
formula basically uniformly at random
there is another way that is very
interesting is the following you first
generate one solution 1 vector in your
space one assignment and then you
generate the formula uniformly at random
conditional that being a solution for
instance in the case of coloring you
draw a vector in the space uniformly at
random and then you draw an instance
conditional or uniformly conditional
next being resolution of the distance
uniformly arrow among all graphs that
have the same number of edges and then
you can do the same for planted case art
etc so there is an interesting way of
way of describing this you can think of
this generation of a planted assignment
as the following I have a vector that is
my coloring my hidden coloring that I
want to communicate to you and the way
the way I will communicate it to you is
that I will give you a list of clauses
that are generated by that process ok so
i generate a vector but i don't give you
the vector i generate closes at random
from the distribution uniformly at
random conditional of being clauses that
are satisfied by that assignment and
then I give you this closest to you or I
generate edges from this graph uniformly
at random subject to now connecting
vertices of different color and they
give this list of vertices from you so
the problem then is that you can ask is
can you may account number of possible
your messages that are compatible with
the output this is the counting problem
or the decision problem is there now
what is the
nucleation problems find the origin and
there is a connection so this is for
instance the expectation of long-dead
number of solution is the conditional
entropy of x given Y now this kind of
problem is also your his own phase
transitions that are closely related to
what I talked before and you know how
high level what happens is that to this
picture of clustering you are the one
cluster that contains the transmitted
solution now why why I want to elaborate
on this planted ensemble is that the
reason won't elaborate oh this is that a
lot of interesting models from
information theory machine learning
statistics etc fit in this framework ok
and ok here I least a few for instance
compressed sensing network analysis
matrix factorization etc we not put any
references ok but you know interestingly
this thing that is random case ought to
run coloring of random graph that was
initiated as a you know just a
conceptual game turns out to be closely
related to all sorts of models that are
in it studying this apply the areas ok
so so no ok so I hope I convinced you of
these two you know this turns out to be
connected with models that are important
for applications in this area and they
contain some beautiful mathematics I
want to spend clubs 10 minute talking
about this right so so far away we
started with the mail we wanted to solve
as hard distances or understand hard
instances but we didn't talk basically
about computation at all as I want to
talk about computation there is a long
history of people that did the following
take your favorite every stick that is
simple and easy to stated etc and an
allowance be able around on formula ok
and often these these heuristics were
based on iterative simple alternative
procedures that modify the graph
the popular method to analyze it is the
ordinary differential equation so you
you prove that these heuristics for a
mark of the evolution of desire istics
can be described by a low-dimensional
state space and for a markov chain
finder a large n limit for this Markov
chain and so this is a long list of
papers but so this is a very interesting
kind of work but it somehow you can go
on forever right you can every time come
up with a slightly smarter a realistic
and try to analyze it and this will be
more and more difficult and we get you
you know bound on satisfiability
threshold etc etc but you know for a
while there didn't seem to be a unifying
concept ok and I think that the unifying
concept in this in this in this area is
again comes in in something from from
physics and is related to the following
idea ok so let's say that we are talking
about coloring for a fixed at vertex I I
call ball I tee the ball of radius T
center at that vertex I and now I can I
can you know talk about these two object
the first one mui g is the marginal
distribution of variable X I when x is a
uniformly random assignment among all
those that satisfy that a proper
coloring so imagine of doing
conceptually the following I sample a
proper coloring for my graph this
assignment of our coloring of all the
vertices and then i compute the marginal
of the color of this coloring on vertex
I the distribution of the color of
ethics I this is mu IG if I'm compute if
I know how to compute this I'm I'm the
king right because by a similar argument
to autumn nayanthara talked about today
earlier I can count the number of
solution if I can compete marginals and
I can also find so
efforts yawn but okay of course this is
difficult to do but what I can tell to
do is the following take the space of
the set of solution that satisfies the
sub graphene used by the ball if you
look at the set of vertices that have
resistance at most D from I this induce
a graph so you can look at the proper
coloring over there graph a pic one
uniformly at random and compute its
marginal and the intuition is that okay
first of all if if things are nice and T
is large but not too large it should be
true that this marginal the thing that
you want to compute is close to the one
that is obtained by sampling from the
ball if this happens then then things
are great because because this kind of
marginal so where the balls can be
computed very quickly all right the
simplest way to compute the stupid way
to compute it is just you take the ball
off sides epsilon times n and then you
generate colorings from this ball but
then you realize that in this random
graph so what happens is that if you
look at the ball of sides epsilon times
log n of radius epsilon times Logan is
with I probability a tree and computing
marginals for a uniform distribution of
our coloring of a treat it's just a
simple dynamic programming operation so
can be done in time that is linear in
the sides of the ball so I can go over a
single bar every single vertex look at
the ball of radius epsilon and compute
you know the induced marginal at the
center and use that as an estimate of my
marginal okay so this is a name it's
called belief propagation in
artificial intelligence and and actually
can be done much more quickly than that
if you think a little bit it can be done
in time that is so far the number of
edges time t using this local tea tree
light properties but that is not not
crucial for what I'm talking about so
this is this belief propagation
algorithm it's looking at all bolts and
computing the inducing induced marginal
at the center now how do you use this
for finding solutions this is one
possible way to do it is ok you you
repeat the following you have a cellular
running set s that are the vertices that
are not have not been decided so far at
the beginning no vertex has been decided
so s is equal to B and then you repeat
the following look at the graph induced
bias so the graph that contains as
compute the corresponding marginals and
then you know for instance take a vertex
in the set uniformly at random and fix
the variable to your value X I star that
is drawn from this distribution and then
you know eliminate this from the graph
ok I bright it a little bit succinctly I
should do a little bit more because if I
fix one variable to write the
neighboring variable that node is not
eliminated the neighboring variable
cannot be right but you understood the
idea you reduce the graph in somewhere
someway and reduce the coloring problem
to a list coloring problem so if these
marginals were the exact marginals under
the uniform distribution on this graph
so if this T index T was not there what
is argan would do is something beautiful
it would generate a uniformly random
coloring so instead of doing this I'm
doing a you a myopic version of this
thing and and I'm generating this thing
okay so now the question is if you try
to do this so this is an algorithm that
in some sense and compasses and unifies
many autistics because it uses in
optimal way the local information on the
graph but doesn't go beyond local
information so when does this happen you
know if you look again at this this this
phase diagram no okay i don't have
really time to explain why but what
should happen is that this is a group
the approximation outside this regime so
if you are below this condensation phase
transition and this again has been
proved in in special cases in the
special models okay so this was suggest
to your fur bieber this algorithm first
of all it will not work well here it
might work well here but not necessarily
because in the process of reducing the
graph you know I am deforming my graph
and deform in my instances oh my my
might undergo another condensation phase
transition so there is another axis that
is somehow time and thus time a box you
know this clusters reduced and you might
undergo another its transition and okay
this this we put forward in a paper few
years ago and and you know there is a
few papers that can confirm this this
picture in particular I mean koja plan
is an analysis of this BP guided
decimation and proves that it has a
threshold that for large K behaves like
to the K over K so this algorithm so to
the K over K is over here and this is a
consistent from Rhodesia ristic that the
to leave a few years earlier and I mean
Corrigan is another algorithm that has
no the best existing guarantee of any
your algorithm 'i'll time elegant
finding solution run notice out and
works below to the killer k over k that
again is you know in the same regime
it's related to this first dynamic
efficiency now you know in the same work
in which they computed the
satisfiability that i shall the measured
paris and the key light and an
improvement over this idea a significant
improvement where this idea the
demonstrated that work quite a bit
better substantially better for k equal
small k so they did k paltry and then
salmon and others the simulation for
four and five and the idea so what they
called it is survey propagation instead
of belief propagation and the idea here
is you can think it are in different way
but you know in one way to think about
it is that instead of doing the
computing the district uniform
distribution considering the uniform
distribution of a solution again you
considered uniform solution of our
clusters again each cluster can be
somehow uniquely identify in / 0 1 star
assignment 01 ? assignment and so you do
this 01 star assignment the uniform
measure is approximately described by
marco random field insane graph and so
you work with that incident with the
original team and okay finally there is
a general argument by gum Anakin Sudan
that suggested this to do Taylor k over
k is probably a threshold for any any
local Albert many algorithm of this type
that look at the bounder neighborhood
and then operates on the basis of that
so I said suggest because they have a
theorem that is for not all equals out
not for salt
that's a one minute there is something
that I didn't talk about okay just one
minute is there's another side of the
world is optimization right so what
happens on this side when you want to
maximize the number of satisfied
assignment and and for instance you know
an interesting in this case it's
interesting already and simpler to study
exercise so we'll take a random acts or
sat instance and okay the terminology
that you know people uses the following
so what you want to conclude to obtain
is in algorithm that provides a strong
reputation ideally that is the following
an algorithm that is polynomial time and
that gives you always an upper bound on
opt on the optimum value this optimum
values between 0 1 1 means that you can
satisfy everything and you want that
this algorithm suet most 1 minus Delta
with a probability of random instances
so it strongly refuses random instances
so if you come from you know so 11 so
this is a theory application is not an
appliqué application together you can
think that you want to use this for for
the following game somebody gives you a
formula and the formula can be either a
random kik source at formula or a
planted there are no kicks or so formula
okay in this case it's easy but you want
to decide between these two hypotheses
now in this case it's easy because X or
sat is the linear structure but you can
do the same for soft and other things
okay so so many people studied this and
so you're using SDP relaxation and for
instance prove the following that ok for
forgetting a recitation so being able to
get even such a loser approximation on
the opt you need the number of closest
to be at least n to the K over 2 so if
you remember this you know experimenting
which you have computation time that
then slowly go down this is telling that
you know you will hit Pauline time at
number of clauses and to the K over 2
instead of n all right and on the other
side yeah there is reason to believe
that no there is no algorithm that we
work below this n to the K over 2 perigo
because the sum of square hierarchy can
so this is this is work by several
people just put it together and
volunteer alright so I hope that that
but that I I convinced you that okay
this is you know models for many
application there is some interesting
mathematics and those souza yes so if I
have to look forward so 11 you know the
cause of model on which people made a
lot of programs are in the physics
language are this problem with 1 l-sb in
which there is these clusters of
solutions that are well defined there
are problems that are somehow considered
you know more complex and one example is
max cut in which the geometry of the
space of nearly optimal solution is
conjectural even more complex ok we
don't yet know the southeast viability
conjecture for small K we know fairly
litter about counting so I talked about
decision and I talked about about
optimization but the picture about
counting is even fewer and okay it would
be nice to get you know somehow sharply
analysis of stp relaxation
questions I wonder like do we know
something about the geometry of social
space i'll say wallet on a CNF so more
than likely no no negation of parables
oh no Nick more connected all connected
I mean solutions are all a social
specific that's always a solution but
yeah I don't know if any result I would
expect that you know firm first of all
it's always satisfiable and second every
day my guess if you if you draw a random
formula for this so something that he
studied a lot in physics is the
ferromagnetic as a model so probably or
another you're probably one can think is
an analogous of the ferromagnetic Ising
model so yeah so I would expect it in
particle monotone you know there is no
no discuss Turing phenomenon want to
swear it because I expected this
phenomenon does not appear there
comment on how you come up with these
very precise predictions about size of
the cluster the physical connection yeah
so one way to do it so in this regime so
really one way to do it is so there is
one prediction so so one way to
understand it is the following
okay so let's start first thing is the
whole you come so people have a very
precise prediction of the number of
solution this here right prediction is
of this type that one over n log debt
and these goes defending the number of
solution under this random variable goes
to some field and there is a formula for
feet so how you come up for a formula
for this fee okay takes a few hours to
describe but one idea is the following
you suppose of adding 1 1 single cruise
okay and or one single variable so you
can think of this debt and M so the
number of your solution for any Bible
and closes so you try to compute these
two type of team and
if you know what is the limit of this
then you're your king okay so how you
compute this well you're starting in a
little bit I'll you you you you look at
this this is water for instance I'm
taking is the probability so call this
the uniform probability distribution of
a solution for a random formula within
variable and closes this is the
probability that whatever that the
closer that the new clothes is satisfied
so so you want to compute with respect
to a it to a random formula the
probability that if I throw a close this
is satisfied okay so this is what what
is related to so I draw a random closer
and then there will be the rest of the
graph that was here before if I know
what is the Joint Distribution of this
tree or K vertices then I'm done now i
can try to compute this joint
distribution simply by localities this
graph so this is the graph G&M i can
compute this joint distribution by not
looking at the whole graph but looking
only at a ball of radius T so I can hope
to do this calculation because for any
fixity this will be very so I get that
reira caution that will give me three
things and then we'll give me this and
then I plug here plug here negative
former so you do this this gymnastics is
not completely trivial but you get a
formula for all this regime firm right a
certain point break down breaks down
here but before that there is this
clustering phase transition so how do
you deal with it so well the way you
deal with it is the following you you
know in this region what happens is that
the total number of solution is still
given by this this guy this kind of
formula but then you take a random
assignment a random coloring a computer
number of solution that are close to
this so this corresponds to repeating
this calculation but putting a different
boundary condition at the bottom of the
tree
see once you do this you know this
computation gives you this number in
terms of a solution of a recursion on a
tree right now it might happen that this
recurrence um if you're lucky this
recursion is a unique solution you're
happy sometimes it's multiple solution
of there's two solution and this
corresponds somehow to there is a strong
correlation between the boundary and the
center of the tree or there is weak
correlation so this gives you to value
see let's say coronation hurts call it
Finn in and fit thought so we thought is
the one that you obtained with the weak
correlation boundary condition so you
initialize the solution with a week you
know correlation here and finley
initialize with a strong and then you
interpret this and in some cases all of
this coming then this is the real number
of solution and we're the number of
solution inside the cluster and
therefore the num lock of the number of
cluster is she thought
is the number of solution mind /
solution or clusters or the logarithm
some trust somehow mysterious that all
of this can be carried out but stop here